talk to me about your morning routine
what does that look like typically
depends on the time of year really okay
so let's say off season and prep
offseason I wake up and I usually just
do a bit of light cardio what sort of
time do you typically get up
it's been brutal lately I've been in
different time zones for the last six
months so it's just whatever time zone
I'm on okay but lately I've just been
not putting on alarm and I've been
waking up about 7 30 8 o'clock or so
lately and I normally wake up and I just
do like a little bit of cardio just like
20 minutes just to make sure my
appetite's gone and then I have a cold
plunge I usually dip my legs in there at
least if not my full body and just like
are up to my waist then shower eat go to
work what will you tend to have off
season what will breakfast look like
again it varies consistently I get sick
of food really quick especially
breakfast foods so I usually don't like
eating eggs when I'm eating a lot of
food so I normally just make a smoothie
and then I'll have like oatmeal like
blended into the smoothie and some like
Ezekiel bread toast and almond butter
okay and then what about prep which I'm
guessing is significantly more dialed
prep evolves and like I just I'm not
trying to like I evolve so I'm very
fluid like my routines are like what
time do you train depends on the time of
year like it's just wherever I feel
natural I just kind of flow into that
state and do what I can and I kind of
thrive in that structure rather than
really regimented but in prep
I'll wake up in the morning and I
usually will like do like a breath work
thing because I get sucked in that and
it's not even for like At first I tried
to do it for like mental to like kind of
like tap deep into my mind and now it's
just related to oxygenate my body before
like waking up doing cardio because I
realized if I did a little bit of breath
work and like just like you know like
Wim Hof style like three rounds of 30
breaths and hold an exhale repeat three
rounds in the morning and then I went
and did cardio I didn't need caffeine I
was wide awake and I could like Blaster
my cardio way easier and I just felt way
better wow and then after that I'll
usually sauna or cold tub and combine it
I'll always cold up if I sauna because I
like finishing with colds and then
cardio will be higher at that point and
then I'll go shower and eat and the goal
that I do in the mornings it's nothing
crazy like it's just simple as that but
I usually try and put my phone on
airplane mode when I go to bed and not
look at it until the shit's done yeah
that's such a hack do you sleep well if
it's on airplane mode it doesn't matter
if I'm gonna guess you sleep with your
phone outside of your bedroom as well
um and I still usually keep it I usually
have an alarm still or I just have it in
the corner of the room and it's on
airplane mode but I just don't it's
basically a break until after my mode
gets turned off yeah are you not
concerned at all there's a lot of talk
on the internet about reducing
inflammation through using cold plunge
when you're trying to maximize
hypertrophy is this something that
you're not particularly worried about
I think there's a lot of and again I'm
not the Science Guy but I've looked into
it too and I never started doing it for
purely recovery and hypertrophy I
started doing it because of my
autoimmune and just overall systemic
inflammation and health and I just knew
that it would be better for me to reduce
my inflammation
and so I what I looked into was it was
saying that immediately after a workout
when you're getting that like high
inflammation response which is we're
sending blood and nutrients to the
muscle to recover that's when you want
to avoid it so typically if I do like a
long like a 10 minute session that's on
my rest day but if I'm just doing it in
the morning I do it in the morning and
then I don't work out till later in the
day and I don't do it after I work out
so I have a full two meals go to sleep
wake up in the morning and I'll do it
then and it hasn't affected me at all if
anything it's it's helped my joints from
being overly inflamed so I can
continually train and push myself so if
I lose like two percent hypertrophy but
my joints feel better to train harder to
me the outcome is just worth it it's a
trade-off yeah yeah what about walks and
stuff like cardio yeah continuing to
just get yourself moving sunlight
exposure stuff like that yeah I think
like do I do it or do the real I
definitely do it more in prep again I
definitely slack off more than I should
in my off season but I do cardio my off
season so that I can eat I usually just
do a treadmill in there but when I'm in
prep I'll just like roam around outside
a little bit after a meal just to make
sure I'm adjusting properly and I also
to take my mind off life sometimes and
just kind of relax but I'm not too like
crazy methodical with these things I
just make sure everything's on point and
then if my digestion never goes to
that's when I start manipulating things
but I'm super consistent with my food so
normally my digestion is pretty good
tell you what's crazy have you ever worn
a glucose monitor one of those things on
the back of your arm if you ever do that
and it doesn't even need to be a
particularly high carb meal but if you
spike your glucose and then go on a walk
the difference is unbelievable really
yeah yeah it just seems to mediate
insulin sensitivity so well yeah
um and there's also muscles I think that
cross basically across your stomach that
when you walk that sort of contralateral
movement that actually helps uh
digestion okay so yeah walks after um
after food Stu McGill the back pain
specialist is one guy that gave me that
forever and ever and ever ago and uh
yeah trying to do that that's one
advantage of living near a park you know
or being in a house
it's hard in Florida though yeah it'll
be like 110 degrees in humid so if I'm
in the office I go take a walk outside
and come back trench and sweat yeah true
it might be good for the uh for the
calorie burn but that's one thing I was
I was talking to a couple of friends
about that moved into this awesome new
apartment complex one of the things that
you don't see is a price that you pay is
if you do want to go out for a walk it's
like five minutes yeah it's five minutes
to get downstairs well if you take the
stairs that could be part of your walk
uh yeah this has a kind of lame though
aren't they they're kind of tough yeah
but going downstairs is at least good
for your knees so true what are you
doing for knee Health are you into the
knees over toes stuff at all have you
gone to this I I I've dabbled in that I
downloaded the app for my dad because he
has any issues and then I don't think he
used it so I just started using it
myself and I just took some things that
like I found I could put into my routine
super easily like walking backwards with
a weight and when I don't have like a
sled I'll do it on the treadmill turned
off yep I'll just turn off the treadmill
and push the tread I'll warm up like
that I go on the stairs walk up it turn
around walk backwards and some videos if
you've got records upstairs yeah I
trained my like tibia rather than just
my calves too some banned stuff pushing
my knee backwards I've definitely
implemented that it seems to be helping
in other news this episode is brought to
you by eight sleep it is unbearably hot
in Austin Texas at the moment and I'm
exclusively being kept Alive by my eight
sleep pod Pro cover the Pod Pro cover
actively cools and heats each side of
the bed so if you or your partner sleep
hot or cold it can keep the temperature
absolutely perfect as you progress
through your night's sleep it'll
actively adjust the temperature based on
your sleep stage it tracks your sleep it
tracks your heart rate variability your
resting heart rate how much you're
breathing throughout the night it's
incredible and it does all of this by
just slipping over the top of an
existing mattress that you have good
sleep is the Ultimate Game Changer and
if you are focusing on your sleep if you
want to improve your rest and your
recovery this is an awesome place to
begin best of all they deliver
internationally and you can get 150 off
any pod Pro cover by going to
eightsleep.com Modern wisdom that's e i
g h t sleep.com slash modern wisdom